My name's Yana and I'm a trainee psychological well-being practitioner. I read the Clinical Psychologist Collective book. I found it really interesting about all the different stories and how people got to become a clinical psychologist. It just amazed me how many different routes there are to get there and there's no perfect way to become one. And this kind of filled me of confidence that no, I'm not doing it wrong and put less pressure on myself. So if you're feeling a bit uneasy about becoming a clinical psychologist, I'd definitely recommend this just to put yourself at ease and everything will be okay.
我叫亚娜，是一名心理健康从业者实习生。我读了《临床心理学家集体》这本书。书中关于各种不同的故事以及人们如何成为临床心理学家的内容让我觉得非常有趣。我惊讶于通往这一职业的途径竟如此之多，而且并没有所谓的“完美路径”。这让我充满信心，意识到我并没有走错路，也减轻了我的自我压力。所以，如果你对成为临床心理学家感到有些不安，我绝对推荐你读读这本书，它能让你安心，一切都会好起来的。
But trust me, you will not put the book down once you start. For three years, trainee psychologists believe they're climbing a ladder that leads straight to a qualified. post but in reality that ladder can stop abruptly you might step off into a job market where roles are scarce jobs are part-time and some psychologists even find themselves signing on at the job centre not because they aren't skilled but because the system really isn't designed for this today we are pulling back the curtain on what it's really like at this stage from someone who's living it right now as an end-stage trainee and someone who's been through it already as a qualified
但相信我，一旦开始读，你就停不下来。三年来，心理学实习生们一直认为自己正在攀登一架直通合格职位的梯子，但现实中，这架梯子可能会突然中断。你可能会步入一个职位稀缺、工作多为兼职的就业市场，有些心理学家甚至发现自己不得不去就业中心登记失业，这并不是因为他们能力不足，而是因为这个系统确实不是为此设计的。今天，我们将揭开这一阶段真实情况的面纱，分享者是一位正处于实习末期的实习生，以及一位已经经历过这一阶段的合格临床医生。
clinician if you want the truth about what it's like to do jump from trainee to qualified, this is the episode for you. And if you find it helpful, please do like and subscribe for more. Hi, welcome along to the podcast. I'm Dr. Marianna, qualified clinical psychologist. And today I'm welcoming back Tanya Well Milligate to the podcast. Hello again, Tanya. Hi, Marian. Thank you for inviting me back for another one. So yeah, looking forward to speaking today. Absolutely. And we really wanted to think about what it's like when you are nearing the end of training or maybe even when you've qualified and then you are having to apply for jobs, which may or may not be there. Certainly in my own experience in 2011, they were not there. Of a cohort of 16 when we qualified, I think three of us had jobs to go to when the course. ended and I was not one of those people. How is the landscape looking currently, Tanya?
如果你想了解从实习生到合格临床医生这一转变的真相，那么这一集就是为你准备的。如果你觉得有帮助，请点赞并订阅以获取更多内容。嗨，欢迎来到本期播客。我是玛丽安娜博士，一名合格的临床心理学家。今天我再次邀请了坦尼娅·威尔·米利盖特来到播客。再次欢迎你，坦尼娅。嗨，玛丽安。谢谢你再次邀请我参加节目。是的，我很期待今天的交流。当然，我们真的很想探讨一下当你接近培训尾声，或者甚至当你已经获得资格却不得不申请那些可能存在、也可能不存在的工作时，那是一种什么样的体验。当然，以我2011年的亲身经历来看，当时确实没有工作。在我们那一届16名毕业生中，我想只有3个人在课程结束时有工作可去，而我并不在其中。坦尼娅，目前的就业前景如何？
Yeah, so I think, so from my, and I guess this is also kind of like my own experiences as a trainee and, you know, coming towards the end of it and in third year, it was quite bittersweet because like you said, coming towards an end, the end is in sight. We're kind of looking forward to kind of finishing, qualifying, not having the pressure of the course and the thesis on us anymore. But then also that means that then we go into the real world and kind of go into qualified life and and stepping into a job. And I think, you know, if three years ago someone said that you might not, you know, you might struggle to find a job as a qualified psychologist, maybe that would make me think a little bit before. I'd have maybe a few more conversations and think
是的，我想从我个人的角度来看，这也是我作为一名实习生在第三年接近尾声时的亲身经历，那种感觉相当苦乐参半。就像你说的，终点就在眼前，我们期待着结束培训、获得资格，不再承受课程和论文的压力。但这也意味着我们将进入现实世界，开始合格后的生活，并步入职场。我想，如果三年前有人告诉我，作为一名合格的心理学家，你可能会难以找到工作，我可能会在之前多思考一下，多进行一些交流，并考虑一下获得资格后的就业前景。
about employment prospects post-qualifying. So I think that's something that myself and my fellow trainees and trainees in third year and other universities that are having conversations about is the availability of those jobs. Because our friends in cohorts above us have struggled a little bit to find employment and secure a job. Sometimes it's possible to do that in your last placement to secure a job. And as you mentioned, you have three trainees in your cohort that were able to do that. But for others, we're talking a couple of months of interviewing and kind of going through the process. And that can be really tricky and a little bit anxiety provoking, you know, if we have other commitments like children or mortgages to pay other responsibilities that mean that being out of work for an extended period of time is very tricky and, yeah, possibly. Yeah, and something I did not envisage in my very newly qualified Dr. Days was joining the queue at the job centre and going and signing on.
所以我认为，我和我的实习生同伴们，以及其他大学三年级的实习生们，都在讨论这些职位的可用性。因为我们上一届的朋友在寻找就业机会和获得工作方面确实遇到了一些困难。有时在最后一次实习期间是有可能获得工作的，正如你提到的，你们那一届有三名实习生做到了。但对于其他人来说，我们谈论的是几个月的面试和流程。这可能会非常棘手，并引发一些焦虑，你知道，如果我们还有其他负担，比如孩子或房贷，或者其他责任，意味着长期失业是非常困难的。是的，我刚获得博士资格时，从未想过自己会去就业中心排队登记。
you know, having to do certain job seeking responsibilities every week and going physically to the job centre to have meetings and be able to, you know, to claim that money. And for me, it was important that I did do that because I didn't know how long I was going to be unemployed and I wanted my kind of national insurance stamps to kind of show the system that I was still existing. And yet it was interesting conversations to have with people in the job centre when they're like, oh, you know, you could apply for this, you could apply for that. And it's like, I know the jobs are coming. Just give me a little bit more time.
你知道，每周都要履行某些求职责任，亲自去就业中心开会，以便能够领取那笔钱。对我来说，这样做很重要，因为我不知道自己会失业多久，而且我希望我的国民保险缴费记录能向系统证明我依然存在。而且，在就业中心与工作人员交谈也很有趣，他们会说：“哦，你可以申请这个，申请那个。”而我的想法是，我知道工作机会会有的，请再给我一点时间。
Yes, I know I could potentially go and, you know, apply to ALDI. But I don't think I'm quite at that stage yet. Like, I really would like to just look for qualified psych jobs. And please just allow me a little bit. more time. Yeah, like, so please, de-shame that process. If you're out of work, you know, a fixed-term contract has ended, you know, there are benefits available. But yes, certainly not what I expected. Yeah, thank you, Marianne, for sharing that because I think, yeah, there is a bit of a stigma around it. It's like, oh, do you have something lined up? Have you done your interviews?
是的，我知道我可能可以去申请阿尔迪超市的工作，但我认为我还没到那个阶段。我真的只想寻找合格的心理学工作。请再给我一点时间。是的，请消除对这个过程的羞耻感。如果你失业了，或者固定期限合同结束了，确实有福利可以领取。但这绝对不是我所预期的。是的，谢谢玛丽安分享这些，因为我认为围绕这件事确实存在一些污名化。人们会问：“哦，你安排好工作了吗？你面试了吗？”
you know and maybe if people feel like they might need to pivot around psychology for a short time or to think about alternative options and yeah there may be a little bit of stigma around that and I think like you said it you know the training is a fixed term contract and it's been three years of obviously a lot of change but in some ways a lot of consistency because we knew for the next three years we'd be on a fixed term contract we'd have it's a salary job we would get paid every month. And so there was security in that over the last three years. But and, you know, arguably before that in assistant psychology posts or RA post, there is that consistency. And, you know, it's a to training, it's like a step ladder and you're kind of going up that. And when you get
你知道，如果人们觉得他们可能需要在心理学领域之外进行短期调整，或者考虑其他选择，这可能会带来一些污名。正如你所说，培训是一个固定期限的合同，这三年里显然有很多变化，但在某些方面也有很多稳定性，因为我们知道未来三年我们会有固定合同，有薪水，每个月都能领到工资。所以过去三年里，这给了我们安全感。而且，可以说在此之前，在助理心理学家或研究助理职位上，也有这种稳定性。这就像一个阶梯，你正在向上攀登。当你到达顶端时，
to the top, it's like, well, I imagine it's going to keep going. But, you know, unexpectedly, you might not see that next bit. And I think that does cause a little bit of anxiety. And so, So, yeah, I mean, we were speaking a little bit about how courses are increasing and how it can be difficult, I guess, with funding through the NHS to fund more positions for qualified psychologists. So I guess that's something to think about as well. I mean, we're a cohort of 56 now. So I'm not sure if there'll be 56 jobs in London, but it's, yeah, there's those kinds of conversation that we're having at the moment.
你会觉得它会一直延伸下去。但出乎意料的是，你可能看不到下一段路。我认为这确实引起了一些焦虑。所以，是的，我们刚才谈到课程数量在增加，以及在NHS（英国国家医疗服务体系）资金有限的情况下，为合格心理学家提供更多职位可能很困难。所以我想这也是需要考虑的一点。我的意思是，我们现在有56人的规模。我不确定伦敦是否会有56个职位，但这些确实是我们目前正在讨论的话题。
Yeah, and of course you're not the only London course. And what we often forget is that other qualified psychologists might have applied last year and might be looking to apply for those jobs as well. And of course, if they've got a one year post-qualification experience, they might be more likely to get that job. So you're not necessarily just competing with your cohort. Like you could be, it's an open market. And yeah, we had a little look before we started recording at the clearinghouse data
是的，当然，伦敦不止你们这一门课程。我们经常忘记的是，其他合格的心理学家可能去年就申请过，现在也可能在寻找这些工作。当然，如果他们有一年的从业经验，他们可能更有可能获得这份工作。所以你并不一定只是在和你的同届同学竞争。这是一个开放的市场。在录音前，我们查看了清算所的数据，
for how course places have changed over the years. And when I trained, there was 15 of us. And it's interesting that actually, even though the numbers have gone up over time, currently they're at 15 again, the course that I trained with. And your course has got much bigger and then has come back down again to kind of the 56.
关于课程名额多年来的变化。我受训时，我们只有15个人。有趣的是，尽管人数随着时间推移有所增加，但目前我受训的那门课程又回到了15人。而你的课程规模扩大了很多，然后又回落到了56人左右。
And it's, yeah, it's sustainability. So I think they do try and predict and plan, but I think a lot of that is, it feels like it's more linked to budgets, how much money they've got to be able to train psychologists rather than necessarily looking at job forecasting. And yeah, what, it's really hard because I think you kind of think, oh, well, I've taken, you know, lower paid work to be able to get onto the doctorate and you, maybe it's this naive hope or trust in the system that you'll be looked after ultimately or eventually. And then when you get qualified, you will have a job
这关乎可持续性。我认为他们确实试图进行预测和规划，但我觉得这更多是与预算挂钩，即他们有多少资金来培训心理学家，而不是真正着眼于就业预测。这真的很艰难，因为你会想：“哦，我已经接受了低薪工作来进入博士课程。”也许这是一种天真的希望，或者对系统的信任，认为最终你会得到照顾，当你获得资格后，你就会有一份工作。
but yeah getting a trainee psychologist role is not a guarantee of employment you know it's hopefully that if you jump through all the right hoops it's a guarantee that you'll come out the other end as a qualified psych the rest is the rest is not promised yeah totally and I think something that we're finding more is you know as we've been saying that the courses have been increasing but also posts have been become more broader in terms of what they're looking for. So you might have in one job advertisement, you know, clinical or counselling psychologist or clinical or counselling or practitioner or CBT therapists. So it's like the pool becomes bigger as well. And so not only are you kind of competing against other trainees, but also qualified psychologists, there are other
但获得实习心理学家的角色并不能保证就业。你知道，希望如果你通过了所有正确的考核，这能保证你最终成为一名合格的心理学家，但其余的并没有承诺。是的，完全同意。我认为我们发现更多的情况是，正如我们所说，课程在增加，但职位的要求也变得更加广泛。所以你可能会在同一个招聘广告中看到：临床或咨询心理学家，或者临床、咨询、从业者或CBT治疗师。所以竞争池也变大了。因此，你不仅是在和其他实习生竞争，还有其他
practitioner psychologists who fall under that. And so there's a lot more to it than yeah maybe rounds of interviews i don't know i'm not sure how they do that do that now um and also a lot of positions being part-time can you know cause a lot of strain on the individual if they're having to kind of juggle more than one job or i know a friend of a friend is working to NHS posts part-time and doing private work you know because they've recently um just bought a house so it's like having to juggle all of those things maybe wasn't something that we'd anticipated prior to kind of applying and doing the training. So yeah, it's kind of opening up this whole other world of post-qualified life. And I think it's, yeah, causing a bit of anxiety.
属于这一范畴的从业心理学家。所以这不仅仅是几轮面试的问题，我不知道他们现在是怎么做的。此外，许多职位是兼职的，如果个人不得不兼顾多份工作，这可能会给他们带来很大压力。我知道有朋友的朋友在NHS做两份兼职工作，同时还做私人业务，因为他们刚买了房子。所以不得不兼顾所有这些事情，可能并不是我们在申请和进行培训之前所预期的。所以，这确实开启了合格后生活的另一个世界，我认为这引起了一些焦虑。
Yeah, and private practice always used to be something that you probably perhaps thought about starting as you were winding down to semi-retire, maybe. And, you know, that's not the case these days for sure. Maybe it was never the case. That might have just been my own assumption. But Yeah, I think for my own imposter syndrome, I didn't start my private practice until 2019, and I'd qualified in 2011. So I definitely felt like I needed some qualified years under my belt. Even then, I still had this imposter syndrome about doing that with eight years post-qualification experience. And I'd also become a mother during those times. So I felt like I'd kind of learned about very new and different ways of kind of understanding psychology and the real world as well.
是的，私人执业过去通常是你可能在考虑半退休时才会想到的事情。当然，现在情况并非如此。也许它从来都不是那样，那可能只是我自己的假设。但我认为，由于我自己的冒名顶替综合症，直到2019年我才开始私人执业，而我是在2011年获得资格的。所以我确实觉得我需要在获得资格后积累几年经验。即便如此，在拥有八年从业经验后，我仍然对私人执业感到冒名顶替综合症。在那段时间里，我也成为了一名母亲。所以我感觉自己学到了理解心理学和现实世界的非常新颖且不同的方式。
But yeah, people are having to think about private practice as a way of primarily, you know, paying the bills. And this is not necessarily a free choice. You know, when I started training, I hand on heart would have said I will be working for the NHS until I retire. That is what I thought I would be doing. That is not what has happened at all. So is it having to make different choices than that which we thought to be able to live our lives? Yeah, totally. And I think there is this kind of moral injury when we think about the NHS and private practice.
但确实，人们不得不将私人执业视为一种主要的谋生手段。这不一定是自由选择。你知道，当我开始培训时，我真心实意地认为我会一直在NHS工作直到退休。那是我认为我会做的事情。但事实完全不是这样。所以，为了生活，我们是否不得不做出与预期不同的选择？是的，完全同意。我认为当我们想到NHS和私人执业时，确实存在一种道德伤害。
And I mean, this can be a whole conversation in itself, isn't it? But yeah, and I think the anxiety also is from a trainee perspective through some of the conversations that I've had is going into it, early. I know you mentioned you spent eight years in the NHS before considering private work. And I've heard that people are one year in post-qualified and I've already started their own practice or renting rooms in London for their own private practice. So yeah, I think that causes me a bit of anxiety because I'm like, wait a minute, I've done, you know, this is my fourth placement. And so I've had a taste of this job role in four different places, but is that enough? And, you know, it's not a qualified case role that I've been doing, been doing a trainee case,
我的意思是，这本身就可以成为一个完整的话题，不是吗？但我认为，从实习生的角度来看，通过我进行的一些对话，这种焦虑也来自于过早进入这一领域。我知道你提到你在NHS工作了八年才考虑私人工作。但我听说有人在获得资格一年后就开始了自己的执业，或者在伦敦租房进行私人执业。所以，是的，我认为这让我感到有些焦虑，因为我在想：“等一下，这是我的第四个实习岗位。”所以我已经在四个不同的地方体验过这个职位，但这足够吗？而且，这不是我一直在做的合格案例角色，我做的是实习生案例，
trainee cases and caseload. Am I confident enough? Do I feel like I need more support? Like, I'm going to miss that from the NHS, that supervision, the kind of clinicians coming together, the MDT, like there's a lot of valuable things there that may be so early on to leave and to move and become more independent. Again, is maybe a bit daunting. But I do appreciate that some people might be in that position as well if it feels like there aren't as many jobs going around. Yeah, absolutely. This isn't an ideal scenario. And I definitely learned so much from my first qualified post about being qualified and about being a clinical psychologist within that team. And finding my feet, finding them quite quickly, I have to say, because they definitely
实习生案例和工作量。我足够自信吗？我觉得我需要更多支持吗？我可能会怀念NHS提供的那些东西，比如督导、临床医生聚在一起、多学科团队（MDT），那里有很多宝贵的东西，如果过早离开并变得更加独立，可能会让人望而生畏。但我确实理解，如果工作机会不多，有些人可能也会处于那种境地。是的，绝对。这不是一个理想的情况。我从第一份合格后的工作中确实学到了很多关于如何成为一名合格的临床心理学家以及如何在团队中工作。我很快就找到了自己的定位，我必须说，因为他们确实
wanted me to be up and running. There wasn't this kid gloves that actually at the time I thought I needed, but actually, I don't think I did. They, you know, they were like, amazing. We've wanted someone in this role for so long, we're delighted to have you, off you go. And that was probably quite empowering, actually, because it kind of like, oh, okay, they see me as competent and ready and able to do this rather than, you know, it's not like, so my experience when I came back from bereavement leave after my dad died is that, yes, I was given a slower pace. I was, you know, more thought given about my capacity and what I could give and what would be maybe a bit too much, it's not like that when you're qualified, that it wasn't like that.
希望我能迅速上手。当时我以为我需要那种“温室保护”，但实际上，我认为我并不需要。他们说：“太棒了，我们在这个职位上等了很久，很高兴你能来，开始吧。”这实际上相当赋能，因为它让我觉得：“哦，好吧，他们认为我有能力、准备好了，能够胜任这份工作。”而不是像我父亲去世后休完丧假回来时那样，我确实得到了更慢的节奏，他们更多地考虑了我的能力以及我能承担多少，什么可能太多了。当你获得资格后，情况就不是那样了。
And that's what I thought I wanted. In hindsight, I didn't get that. And I'm glad I didn't because that would have fed into the narrative that I couldn't do it. But that said, whilst I might never have applied for that job that I did get and was in for almost four years, if there'd been more jobs available closer to home, so glad I did that work. I loved it. I loved, love, loved it. I learned so much. And it was, yeah, I think back very fondly to those times, working in those two services because it was split post. But yeah, I definitely am pleased that I didn't go straight into private practice because there's something about
那是我以为我想要的。事后看来，我并没有得到那种保护。我很高兴我没有得到，因为那会助长我无法胜任的叙事。话虽如此，虽然如果离家更近的地方有更多工作，我可能永远不会申请那份我确实得到并工作了近四年的工作，但我很高兴我做了那份工作。我爱它，我非常、非常、非常爱它。我学到了很多。而且，是的，我非常怀念那段时光，在两个服务部门工作，因为那是分拆职位。但确实，我很高兴我没有直接进入私人执业，因为有些事情是
holding a clinical caseload as a qualified member of staff that did take a bit of adjusting. I would say. Suddenly, you're signing your name and you have clinical responsibility, I definitely felt like I needed some support leaning into that aspect. And had I just been trying to set up my business, do all of those things, think about referral, think about marketing, and holding clinical responsibility, and working out what was okay for private practice and what wasn't and what needed bumping up. Like, for me, personally, that would have been a stretch too far. So I'm very pleased that I had that period of employed life to be able to allow me to make
作为一名合格的员工承担临床工作量确实需要一点适应。我想说。突然间，你签下自己的名字，承担临床责任，我确实觉得我需要一些支持来适应这一方面。如果我当时只是试图建立我的业务，处理所有这些事情，考虑转诊，考虑营销，承担临床责任，并弄清楚什么是私人执业可以接受的，什么是不可以的，什么需要升级。对我个人而言，那将是一个太大的跨度。所以我很高兴我有一段受雇的生活，让我能够完成
that transition. Have you got any thoughts on that, Tanya? Yeah, it just reminded me of this lecturer that came into our university a couple of weeks ago. And I think she worked inpatient. and I think she said that when she qualified, she was the only psychologist in the trust. And it's a trust towards us south of the country.
那种转变。坦尼娅，你有什么想法吗？是的，这让我想起了几周前来到我们大学的一位讲师。我想她在住院部工作，她说当她获得资格时，她是该信托机构中唯一的心理学家。那是该国南部的一个信托机构。
And we were all shocked. We were all like, how? Her supervisor was not in the trust. They had to externally hire a supervisor and kind of pay for that through the NHS. And she had been in that role since she qualified and she's still in that role. And it really is amazing because I think she's doing
我们都惊呆了。我们都在想：“怎么会？”她的督导不在该信托机构内。他们必须通过NHS在外部聘请督导并为此付费。她从获得资格起就一直担任那个职位，现在依然在那里。这真的很了不起，因为我认为她正在
such amazing work and clearly so needed in an inpatient setting. And I remember she said when she qualified, she thought, you know, I've got a job so that's great. I'm going into impatient. I don't have that experience or like she didn't have, feel like her placements were that relevant to her qualified role. But she kind of said that's okay. So she took up private work almost as a way to top up her experiences, which is the first time I heard of that, which was really interesting because she said, well, I've never really done OCD during my placements. So let me just privately work to find an OCD client to kind of explore that, gain that to a certain sort of like competent level, understand the kind of how to deliver the intervention. And so, you know,
做着如此出色的工作，显然在住院环境中非常需要她。我记得她说当她获得资格时，她想：“我知道我有一份工作，这太棒了。我要去住院部了。”她没有那种经验，或者说她觉得她的实习经历与她的合格职位不太相关。但她觉得那没关系。所以她几乎把私人工作作为一种补充经验的方式，这是我第一次听说，这非常有趣，因为她说：“好吧，我在实习期间从未真正处理过强迫症（OCD）。所以让我私下工作来寻找一个强迫症客户，去探索它，将其提升到某种胜任水平，了解如何提供干预措施。”所以，你知道，
when it comes to it in my inpatient work, I know how to, you know, how to do that. It doesn't feel like it's first time round. Yeah, which I found really interesting. So I didn't think that, you know, the private work could also supplement, you know, some of the things that you wouldn't necessarily get in certain qualified NHS posts to kind of boost up your experience. Yeah, that is interesting. And I think I tend to only work with people using the skill set that I had in the NHS or, you know, I might have done some additional training, but it's certainly in those areas that the passion was ignited for me in my kind of client work in the NHS. But yeah, like imagine being the only, the only psychologist.
当我在住院部工作中遇到这种情况时，我知道该怎么做。感觉不再是第一次了。是的，我觉得这非常有趣。所以我没想到私人工作也可以补充你在某些合格的NHS职位中不一定能获得的经验，从而提升你的能力。是的，这很有趣。而且我认为我倾向于只使用我在NHS中拥有的技能集与人们一起工作，或者我可能接受了一些额外的培训，但这确实是在NHS客户工作中点燃我激情的领域。但是，想象一下成为唯一的心理学家，
like, oh, I think I'd find that quite lonely. Like, I really enjoyed our kind of wider psychology kind of away days and events where we could all be inspired by one another's practice and eat biscuits. And like, yeah, I definitely like the energy of being around other people. And I guess this is why I've curated this aspiring psych community, really, in the membership. I like learning from others and being inspired by others. I think I would find it quite difficult to be the only. Yeah, hmm, not something I've considered. Yeah, definitely.
哦，我想我会觉得很孤独。我真的很喜欢我们那种更广泛的心理学离职日和活动，在那里我们可以从彼此的实践中获得灵感并吃饼干。而且，是的，我绝对喜欢和其他人在一起的能量。我想这就是为什么我在会员社区中策划了这个有抱负的心理学家社区。我喜欢向他人学习并受到他人的启发。我想如果我是唯一的心理学家，我会觉得很难。是的，嗯，这不是我考虑过的事情。是的，绝对。
And I think there is, you know, we kind of spoke about having like that bonders trainees. But also I think under the NHS, you do have that kind of shared identity. And if it is going on away days or just, you know, even now we're thinking about planning our Christmas do like these are like things that you'd get in the NHS which obviously you do pay for it doesn't get funded they don't have the money for that but if there is something in that i guess in that struggle of working things out in the NHS that really ties you together um which is really nice that maybe yeah you wouldn't have to have or you have to kind of curate a little bit more um in private work for sure yeah we definitely do have to fund it all ourselves and it's reminded me of a post i saw on
而且我认为，我们谈到了作为实习生建立的那种纽带。但我也认为在NHS下，你确实有一种共享的身份。如果是去离职日，或者只是，你知道，即使现在我们正在考虑计划我们的圣诞聚会，这些都是你在NHS中会得到的东西，显然你需要为此付费，它不是由资金资助的，他们没有钱做那个，但如果NHS在解决问题时确实有一种挣扎，那真的会把你们联系在一起，这真的很好，也许在私人工作中你不需要，或者你必须更刻意地去策划。是的，我们确实必须自己承担所有费用，这让我想起了我在
social media the other day if you saw it someone was celebrating their long service award it was either 30 years or 50 years in the NHS and they'd been given a little plastic window little plastic cellophane bag with a single circular tea bag in it and it said thank you for your you know 50 years of service or 30 years of service whatever it was here's a little treat and And it's like, never more have I remembered what it's like to work for the NHS than that gift, you know. And to someone who's worked in corporate industry where you get, you know, your choice of sparkling drinks or, you know, a lovely coffee machine and, you know, this, that and the other. And would you like some whipped cream on that? Like, yeah, never more has there been a stark comparison of, oh yeah, I get it.
社交媒体上看到的一篇帖子。如果你们看到了，有人在庆祝他们的长期服务奖，要么是NHS工作30年或50年，他们得到一个小塑料窗、小塑料玻璃纸袋，里面有一个圆形的茶包，上面写着：“感谢你50年或30年的服务，无论是什么，这是一个小礼物。”那种感觉，我从未像那一刻那样记得在NHS工作是什么感觉。对于一个在企业界工作过的人来说，你会得到你选择的起泡饮料，或者一台可爱的咖啡机，等等。而且你会想在上面加点鲜奶油吗？是的，从未有过如此鲜明的对比，哦，是的，我明白了。
I remember. Yeah, I totally. That's hilarious. And yeah, it just made me think about how, you know, at this stage, we are also thinking about where we want to be, if that's in the NHS or, you know, if we're thinking about private work at some point. And just pulling upon our interests. So maybe if I could, yeah, I think the next thing I wanted to maybe just mention is how, again, that kind of like reframe on this situation about trainees like figuring out. out what they like and what they don't like in terms of like clinical work and how that can inform what they do. Yeah, I think that's sort of. Yeah, absolutely. Are there any kind of last
我记得。是的，我完全同意。这太搞笑了。而且，是的，这让我想到了在这个阶段，我们也在考虑我们想去哪里，是在NHS，还是在某个时候考虑私人工作。并利用我们的兴趣。所以也许如果我可以，是的，我想接下来提到的另一件事是，这种对实习生弄清楚他们喜欢什么和不喜欢什么的情况的重新框架，以及这如何能为他们所做的事情提供信息。是的，我想那是某种。是的，绝对。还有什么最后的
reflections or things we could consider before we finish today, Tanya? Yeah. And I guess I'd been thinking a little bit about, again, a positive reframe about this kind of situation with post-qualifying options for us trainees. And I guess placement is a good. time where we can figure out you know what what it is we like and don't like and for some of us me included I think having such varied placement experiences I'm not quite sure where I'd want to go to be qualified but I think I've realized that that's okay and I can use qualified life as an opportunity to kind of explore that a little bit more but it's also yeah leaning into interest and
反思或我们在今天结束前可以考虑的事情吗，坦尼娅？是的。我想我一直在思考，再次对我们实习生获得资格后的选择这种情况进行积极的重新框架。我想实习是一个很好的时间，我们可以弄清楚我们喜欢什么和不喜欢什么。对于我们中的一些人，包括我，我认为拥有如此多样化的实习经历，我不确定我获得资格后想去哪里，但我意识到那没关系，我可以利用合格后的生活作为一个机会去进一步探索。但这也是，是的，倾听兴趣，
so over training I've been becoming more and more interested in yoga and I've been maybe thinking about if I could integrate that into therapy and do like a yoga therapy course or do yoga teacher training and see how that can inform clinical practice or kind of vice versa. I have a really good friend who's an artist and so she's thinking a little bit about integrating art into her work or doing any extra training. So I think, you know, although we have this training that kind of gears us up to a certain level, we are, you know, we are still humans, we are still individual, we have our interests. And so maybe now that, you know, we're thinking about post-qualified options.
所以在培训期间，我对瑜伽越来越感兴趣，我可能一直在想如果我能把它整合到治疗中，做一个瑜伽治疗课程，或者进行瑜伽教师培训，看看这如何能为临床实践提供信息，或者反之亦然。我有一个很好的朋友是艺术家，所以她正在考虑将艺术整合到她的工作中，或者进行任何额外的培训。所以我想，虽然我们有这种培训让我们达到一定水平，但我们仍然是人类，我们仍然是独立的个体，我们有我们的兴趣。所以也许现在我们正在考虑获得资格后的选择。
We're thinking, how can we become individuals again? You know, how can we find that route that we want to take individually, as well as, you know, having the back of being clinical psychologist, but integrating some of those things. And I've also found that LinkedIn has been really helpful to kind of speak about some of those things and kind of enter into a world of networking and trying to find kind of like-minded people, people who align with those interests. And I think that's really helpful maybe thinking about,
我们正在思考，我们如何才能再次成为个体？你知道，我们如何才能找到我们想要单独采取的那条路线，以及作为临床心理学家的背景，但整合其中一些东西。我也发现LinkedIn在谈论其中一些事情方面非常有帮助，并进入了一个网络世界，试图寻找志同道合的人，与这些兴趣一致的人。我认为这对于考虑
post-qualified kind of options and building that network and finding certain opportunities so I think LinkedIn has been helpful and that's also how we got introduced so I think yeah helpful in many ways absolutely I love LinkedIn and at the time of recording I think I'm about 19 and a half thousand connections on there so I really do love the variety of conversations and we've also just yesterday I recorded an episode entirely on using LinkedIn as a kind of psychology and mental health professional. So yeah, if people are like LinkedIn, really, do listen out for that one. Tanya, I've loved our conversation. It's been so useful to think about what this
获得资格后的选择并建立那个网络和寻找某些机会非常有帮助，所以我认为LinkedIn很有帮助，这也是我们被介绍认识的方式，所以我认为，是的，在很多方面都有帮助。绝对，我喜欢LinkedIn。在录音时，我想我在那里有大约19500个联系人，所以我真的很喜欢各种各样的对话。而且就在昨天，我录制了一集完全关于使用LinkedIn作为心理学和心理健康专业人士的内容。所以，是的，如果人们觉得“LinkedIn，真的吗？”，请务必听听那一集。坦尼娅，我喜欢我们的对话。思考这种
evolving landscape of kind of qualified life looks like right now. Thank you for your thoughtful time and consideration. I'm wishing you all the best with your thesis, with the rest of your final year and with securing a job that feels like a bit of you. Thank you, Marian. Yeah, it's been a pleasure speaking today and having new reflections about qualified life. So thank you. Appreciate it. Thank you so much. Stay in touch. Take care. Thank you so much again for Tanya's time in speaking with us. Has it resonated with you? What stage of your career are you at? Let's go wild in the comments. And please do let me know whether you're watching on YouTube or whether you're listening as mp3. I love this chance to connect with you and I hope that you like being here too. If you do,
不断演变的合格生活景观现在是什么样子非常有用。感谢你深思熟虑的时间和考虑。祝你在论文、最后一年剩下的时间里以及获得一份让你感觉良好的工作方面一切顺利。谢谢，玛丽安。是的，今天能进行交流并对合格生活有新的反思是一种荣幸。所以谢谢你。非常感谢。谢谢你。保持联系。保重。再次非常感谢坦尼娅抽出时间与我们交谈。这引起了你的共鸣吗？你处于职业生涯的哪个阶段？让我们在评论区畅所欲言吧。请务必让我知道你是在YouTube上观看还是在听MP3。我喜欢这个与你联系的机会，也希望你喜欢在这里。如果你喜欢，
please like, please subscribe, please show me your support. That really is the kindest thing you can do for any podcaster or creator that you rate and it doesn't cost you a penny. And the other day someone even said that when they're watching on YouTube, they choose to watch the adverts because they know that's their way of giving back in a way that doesn't cost them but does help me to cover my costs to create this content for you. So if you wanted to do the same, I'd be so very grateful. If you would like to go one step further and be one of my biggest fans, you can do that by joining my paid community, which is on YouTube with Dr. Marianne Trent and Apple where I'm the aspiring psychologist podcast. You might choose to do this because you're a
请点赞，请订阅，请向我展示你的支持。这真的是你能为你评价的任何播客或创作者做的最友善的事情，而且它不会花费你一分钱。前几天甚至有人说，当他们在YouTube上观看时，他们选择观看广告，因为他们知道这是他们回馈的一种方式，不会花费他们，但确实能帮助我支付创建这些内容的成本。所以如果你想做同样的事情，我会非常感激。如果你想更进一步，成为我最大的粉丝之一，你可以通过加入我的付费社区来做到这一点，该社区在YouTube上的“玛丽安·特伦特博士”频道和Apple上的“有抱负的心理学家播客”中。你可能选择这样做，因为你是一名
qualified clinician or just because you want to be able to show me your support and tell me that you really do rate this content. The podcast, itself will always remain free. I will never ring fence or gate keep that. But this really does help me to cover my costs because this podcast takes me about two days a week to record, to research, to edit, to do all of those good things and the emails alongside it. So yeah, that is not a small amount of time. So any contribution you can make is so gratefully received. then let this be your guide with this podcast
合格的临床医生，或者只是因为你想向我展示你的支持，并告诉我你真的很看重这些内容。播客本身将永远保持免费。我永远不会设置围栏或限制访问。但这确实能帮助我支付成本，因为这个播客每周大约需要我两天的时间来录制、研究、编辑、做所有这些好的事情以及随之而来的电子邮件。所以，是的，这不是一小段时间。因此，你所能做的任何贡献都将受到非常感激的接收。那么让这成为你这个播客的指南，
that's your side you'll be on your way to being qualified It's the aspiring psychologist podcast with Dr Marianne Tren My name is Beth and I'm a psychological well-being practitioner from Newcastle
那是你的一面，你将走上获得资格的道路。这是玛丽安·特伦特博士的“有抱负的心理学家播客”。我叫贝丝，我是来自纽卡斯尔的心理健康从业者。
I just wanted to say the biggest thank you to the contributors of the clinical psychologist collective book I've enjoyed reading this so much and loved having an insight into the range of backgrounds and experiences. People have prior to applying for the doctorate. And it's been really interesting seeing the potential barriers to the application as well and how I can try and work around this. I really started to doubt myself and whether I was good enough to apply for the clinical
我只是想对《临床心理学家集体》一书的贡献者们表示最大的感谢。我非常喜欢阅读这本书，也很喜欢深入了解人们在申请博士学位之前所拥有的各种背景和经历。看到申请的潜在障碍以及我如何尝试解决这些问题也非常有趣。我真的开始怀疑自己，怀疑自己是否足够优秀去申请临床
psychology doctorate. But this has really given me the confidence boost that I needed to give it a shot. So the biggest thank you ever. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
心理学博士学位。但这确实给了我所需要的信心提升，让我去尝试一下。所以，最大的感谢。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。